السلاح الروسي الاكثر شهره وانتشارا
واستخداما في العالم بيع منه اكثر من 70
مليون قطعه خلال 60 عاما الماضيه ولقب
بسلاح القرن انها بندقيه كلاشنكوف فخر
الصناعه العسكريه الروسيه
[موسيقى]
47 هذا السلاح الرشاش لا يعتبر سلاحا
عاديا وانما هو فخر واسطوره الصناعه
الحربيه الروسيه الحروب والنزاعات في
القرن الحادي والعشرين لم تخلو من حضور
هذا السلاح
وبكميات هائله تقارير صنفته على انه اكثر
الاسلحه قتلا للبشر من جميع الانواع
الاخرى من الاسلحه الحديثه مجتمعه بعد
نهايه الحرب العالميه الثانيه وبدايه
الحروب الاهليه والاكثر استخداما من قبل
الجماعات المتطرفه هذا السلاح الاسطوري تم
ابتكاره وتصميمه على يد المهندس السوفيتي
الشهير ميخائيل تيموفيتش كلاشنكوف اثناء
اقامته في المستشفى خلال الحرب العالميه
الثانيه ميخائيل قرر عام
1945 ان يبتكر سلاحا اليا يطلق طلق
وفي عام
1947 اكمل ميخائيل تصميمه للسلاح وعرضه في
مسابقه اسلحه خفيفه بالاتحاد السوفيتي
ليظهر قدرات متطوره وخارقه بالنسبه
للاسلحه في ذلك الوقت ويحتل المرتبه
الاولى
ومنذ تلك اللحظه لم تعد كلمه كلاشنكوف
اسما لمواطن سوفيتي فقط وانما اسمه اشهر
سلاح في ميادين القتال ميخائيل غادر
الحياه عام 2013 عن 95 عاما تاركا وراءه
ايقونه تطورت قدراتها القتاليه عبر الزمن
واصبحت الاخطر والاشهر في العالم
ورغم ان ملايين الاغرياء تم قتلهم بهذه
البندقيه الا ان مخترعها كلاشنكوف دافع
عنها قائلا انه صنع
وهو الامر الذي جعلك كلاشنكوف من اخف
الاسلحه في العالم اما فيما يخص طول
البندقيه فكان سلاح اي كي سبعه واربعون
يصل طوله في وضعيه الطي الى
64.5 سم في حين زاد طوله 12 الحديثه في
وضعيه الطي الى
72.5 سم
كلاشنكوف يصنف اليوم على انه اكثر الاسلحه
دمويه والاكثر انتشارا والاكثر تغييرا
للعبه في تاريخ التسلح العسكري لكنه ايضا
وضع بصمته في تاريخ العصيان والثورات
والانقلابات كثير من المصممين حول العالم
حاولوا ابتكار سلاح جديد يتفوق على بندقيه
كلاشنكوف وتعتبر بندقيه ام 16 الامريكيه
الاقرب في منافسه كلاسين كوب روسيا
ما رايكم لماذا لم تستطع اي بندقيه حتى
الان ازاحه بندقيه كلاشنكوف الروسيه من
مكانتها في عالم الحروب